assault weapons ban what is your
personal thought did you vote for the
military
feinstein has filed
i will answer that question as follows
i've had she's talked to me about her
assault weapons ban
the new one she believes in it fervently
and i admire for that
i'll take a look at that as i've
indicated to you folks
we're going to have votes on all kinds
of issues dealing with guns
and i think everyone will be well
advised to read the legislation before
they determine how they're going to vote
for it
frank yeah okay last question um if you
found out that the
gitmo office to actually close i'm sorry
we found out that the gitmo office
actually closed down gitmo
has actually shut down itself why hasn't
been closed down just yet
as promised by the president what is
closed miss
the actual office to close down gitmo
has been closed itself
i think we've given you about all the
information we have available okay
on that on that subject
coming up tonight on c-span 2 a senate
health subcommittee examines the
shortage of primary care physicians
then a national journal forum looks at
medicare costs
later senators speak on the confirmation
of senator john kerry to be the next
secretary of state
currently 30 percent of u s doctors are
primary care physicians
tuesday the senate health subcommittee
on primary health examined the growing
shortage of primary doctors
this is just under two hours
let's go
which is going to cover i believe an
enormously important issue i want to
thank
a ranking member mike enzi for his work
he and i have worked together on a
number of issues over the years
and i look forward to a productive
working relationship
vermont is a rural state i know
something about rural problems his state
is a lot more rural
so we will see how we can go forward
together
um in our country today
now before i begin that let me thank all
of our panelists for being here we have
a
great set of panelists from all over the
country and we very much appreciate
them being here and we thank them for
the work they do every day
providing health care and doing research
uh in our country today i think as many
people know
we spend almost twice as much
as do the people of any other country
per capita
on health care that's about 18 percent
of our gdp
and yet our health care outcomes
in terms of life expectancy infant
mortality and disease prevention
are not particularly good in terms of
international comparisons
and one of the reasons for that is that
we have a major crisis
regarding primary health care access
which results in lower quality health
care for our people
and greater expenditures
lower quality health care and yet we end
up because of the crisis
in primary health care spending
substantially more than we should
today 57 million people in the united
states one in five americans cannot see
a doctor
when they need to lack of access to a
primary care provider
is a national problem but those who are
most
impacted are people who are low income
minorities seniors
and people who live in rural communities
whether it's vermont or wyoming
as we've seen time and time again with
dental care
mental health and other health care
issues the groups that need
health care the most are the least
likely
to receive it the good news is that just
eleven months from now we will be
providing
health insurance to 30 million more
americans
through the affordable care act the bad
news is that we don't know
how we are going to be providing primary
health care
to those americans who now will have
health
insurance let me just rattle off
some statistics that i think should be
of concern
to the congress and in fact to all
americans
not widely known but maybe dr wilper
will talk about this
when he testifies approximately 45
000 people every single year
die in the united states of america
because they do not have health
insurance
and they do not get to a doctor on time
45 000 americans
according to the health resources and
service administration
we need sixteen thousand primary care
practitioners
to meet the need that exists today with
a ratio of one provider to two thousand
patients
over fifty two thousand primary care
physicians
will be needed by 2025.
in 2011 about 17 000 doctors graduated
from american medical schools despite
the fact that over half of patient
visits
are for primary care only seven percent
of the nation's medical school graduates
now choose
a primary care career
seven percent nearly all of the growth
in the number of doctors per capita over
the last several decades
has been due to a rise in the number of
specialists
between 1965 and 1992
the primary care physician the
population ratio
grew by only 14 while the specialist
the population ratio exploded by 120
percent
the average primary care physician in
the united states
is 47 years of age and one quarter
are near retirement in 2012
it took about 45 days
for new patients to see a family doctor
up from 29 days in 2010
in other words even if you can find a
family
provider it often takes a lot longer
than it should
to see him or her only 29 percent of u.s
primary care practices provide access to
care
on evenings weekends
or holidays as compared to 95 percent of
physicians
in the united kingdom in other words our
culture is don't get sick
on saturday sunday or night nine to five
works pretty good
half of emergency room patients
would have gone to a primary care
provider
if they had been able to get an
appointment at the time
one was needed
in other words we are wasting billions
of dollars
because people end up in the emergency
room
for non-emergent care because they can't
find a primary health care physician
in my view and i think the view of all
of the experts who have studied the
issue
primary care is intended to be and
should be
the foundation of the us health care
system
in 2008 americans made almost a billion
office visits to the doctor 50 percent
of those visits
were to primary care doctors have
according to virtually every study done
on this issue
access to primary health care results in
better
health outcomes reduced health
disparities
and lower spending by not only reducing
emergency room but when you get people
to the doctor when they should
they don't get sicker than they
otherwise would be and end up in the
hospital
at great cost the problem we are
discussing is clearly a national problem
existing in 50 states in the country but
it is
even worse for particular geographic
regions
the ratio of primary care doctors in
urban areas
is 100 per 100 000 people
double the ratio in rural communities
where it is 46
per 100 000 so urban communities clearly
have problems
rural communities have even greater
problems
65 percent of primary health care
professional shortage areas
are in rural counties my own state
we do much better than the rest of the
country in terms of primary health care
providers
per hundred thousand and yet i can tell
you
that in the state of vermont people
often have a difficulty
getting the to the primary care provider
they need
although 20 percent of americans live in
rural areas
only 9 percent of physicians practice
there one of the significant differences
between the us
health care system and the health care
systems of other highly developed
countries
which could significantly explain why we
spend so much more
than other countries around the world is
the ratio of primary care physicians
to specialists in the united states
roughly
speaking 70 percent
of our practitioners our specialist
30 percent our primary health care
providers
around the rest of the world that number
is exactly the opposite
about 70 percent of their practitioners
are primary health care providers
30 percent are specialists what can
congress do
to address this very serious issue let
me just rattle off
a few points and give the mic over to
senator enzi
first and foremost clearly we must
address the issue
of primary care reimbursement rates
specialists earn as much for their
lifetime of practice
as much as 2.8 million dollars more than
primary
care providers so if you're going into
medicine if you're a specialist
you can earn throughout your lifetime
almost three million dollars more
than a primary care practitioner
radiologist
and gastroenterologist for example have
incomes
more than twice that of family
physicians
the system for setting physician
reimbursement in this country
is largely determined by the 31
physicians who sit on the american
medical association committee
called the relative value scale update
committee
generally called rock the rock whose
payment recommendations are accepted by
the centers for medicare
and medicaid services over 90 percent of
the time
and are adopted by many private insurers
is dominated by
specialists so specialists sitting on
the committee
determine reimbursement rates we have to
look at that issue
medicare has promoted the growth of
residencies in specialty fields
rather than primary health care by
providing significant sums
10 billion each year to teaching
hospitals
without requiring any emphasis on
training
primary care doctors serious issue
thirdly unlike other nations which
provide significant financial support
for medical school education we by and
large do not do this
in this country and the result is the
median debt
for medical students upon graduation is
more than a hundred and sixty thousand
and almost a third of medical school
graduates leave school more than two
hundred thousand dollars in debt now if
you're leaving school two hundred
thousand dollars in debt what are you
gonna do
you're gonna try to figure out how i
make as much money as possible
to deal with that debt and you're gonna
gravitate toward those fields which pay
you
higher uh incomes so if we're going to
attract young people into primary health
care
we must make that profession more
financially attractive
in other words we must address the issue
of how reimbursement rates are set for
medicare
which impacts reimbursement rates for
all physicians
second of all in recent years and i've
worked on this issue other members have
worked on this issue
we have greatly expanded community
health centers around the country
and community health centers provide
very good quality
cost effective health care we need to do
more than that we've made progress
we need to make more progress we need in
recent years we have significantly
increased funding for the national
health service corps
which says to somebody that if you're
graduating medical school two hundred
thousand dollars of debt
we are going to help you address that
debt will help you pay it off
if you practice in underserved areas it
is working
it has worked we've made progress we
need to make more progress
in that teaching health centers studies
have shown that residents trained in
community health centers or rural
communities
are more likely than those trained in
other settings to make a career
practicing
in underserved or rural areas the thc
program was the only new investment
in graduate medical education in the
affordable care act
and the five-year funding was only 230
million dollars we've got to expand
that concept we've also got to take a
hard look at the role
of allied health providers nurse
practitioners
and others how do we better utilize
those people in the provision of health
care so
we've got a very very serious problem
the lives of
thousands of people depend upon what we
do
and i am very excited about the
wonderful panelists that we have at this
uh hearing and now i'd like to hear from
senator enzi who has done so much work
in this area
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
holding this hearing and
i'm glad to be joining you for my first
hearing as ranking member of this
subcommittee
and i look forward to working with you
i'd also like to thank the witnesses for
taking time out of their schedules to be
with us i particularly like to welcome
tony deck lever from cheyenne
she's worked with me and my staff on
health care workforce issues for a
number of years
and i appreciate that you made the long
trip across the country
to be here it's a pleasure to welcome
all the witnesses to our hearing
the issue of improving access to primary
care services and aligning our health
care workforce
is one that's important to all of us but
one that's especially significant
given the obstacles that people face in
wyoming
nearly the entire state is considered a
frontier or rural
county 47 percent of the population
lives in a county with fewer than six
residents per square mile according to
the wyoming department of health
approximately 200 000 residents live in
health professional shortage areas
with inadequate access to primary or
dental care
there are serious access challenges in
wyoming that require creative solutions
to resolve
we have one hospital that's served by a
physician that
every time we lose that physician the
hospital closes
to that end the state's developed a
number of programs that are tailored to
meet the specific needs
of a frontier state where distance
presents the biggest barrier to
accessing a doctor
we say that we have miles and miles of
miles and miles
and recruiting healthcare professionals
to live and work there is an ongoing
challenge
the wyoming department of health
operates its own health professional
loan repayment program
along with a physician recruitment grant
program
these programs work to reduce the high
cost of health professional graduate and
training programs
which is often a deterrent to working in
primary care or other lower income
medical fields
the wyoming health resources network
represents another innovative approach
to improving access and reducing primary
care workforce shortages
this collaborative arrangement between
the major medical
and health professional societies the
university of wyoming
and other key partners maintains an
extensive database on wyoming healthcare
facilities and their need for
professionals
sharing information more effectively
allows for better allocation of
resources
and manpower at a time when the fiscal
climate limits
are our ability to spend money on the
problem
there's more that can be done to better
align federal programs to meet the needs
of rural and frontier states
the criteria that determine eligibility
for federal funds to support
rural health programs are based on
factors that make it difficult to prove
the needs of the underserved in rural
and frontier areas
for example one provider per thirty five
hundred people in new york city
is entirely different than thirty five
hundred people living in fremont or
campbell county
in addition we need to think more
creatively about how to use
technology services to improve
telemedicine capabilities
so that where a person lives has less
impact on the level of care they're able
to receive
the advancement of more powerful
wireless technology has substantial
potential
to remotely link individuals across the
country to deliver health care
in more accessible settings we've had
quite a bit of success with that with
some of the veterans outreach
clinics where they use telemedicine
extensively
with nurse practitioners being in charge
of handling the equipment
and a doctor on the other end of the tel
the telemedicine
i hope this hearing will make it clear
that we need to think more creatively
and figure out ways in which all
americans can better access
primary care services and ways to ensure
health care professionals are employed
where they're most needed i look forward
to hearing from our witnesses on what
needs to be done to solve these problems
at the federal state and local level
again i want to thank the witnesses for
their participation
i want to thank the chairman for his his
great list of
suggestions on things that need to be
done and i'm sure that we have the
capability to come up with
solutions to this committee senator
nancy thank you thank you very much uh
senators will get five minutes
senator warren was here first senator
warren
yes no i just want to thank you very
much uh
for holding this hearing uh mr chairman
uh i am
very uh interested in the question about
how we equalize
access for all of our citizens and
particularly interested in the question
about how we make the right investments
to lower the overall cost
of health care i think the chairman said
it best when he said what we're looking
for
is better outcomes at lower costs and
that that is the peculiar role that the
federal government can make
if it makes the right upfront investment
so i'm looking forward to hearing from
each of the panelists
i also want to thank the ranking member
i think the comments about access and
the reminder
that is very different in a large city
than it is from a very rural area
are comments that are well taken and one
for us to remember
carefully and also the reminder that
that can have very different
consequences even in a state like
massachusetts
where obviously we have a
very extensive health care services
in some areas but it still leaves us
with parts of the people of the
population in massachusetts
with difficulties in accessing care
sometimes distance is less the challenge
but costs can remain the challenge and
transportation
even within close areas can be a serious
challenge so
i appreciate the reminder of the
diversity
of issues that we face in making sure
that all of our citizens
have good access thank you mr chairman
thank you very much senator warren
senator baldwin thank you mr chairman
i will not use the allotted time in its
entirety and apologize to the panel that
i'm going to have to sneak out to attend
another committee meeting and return i
hope
for the q a but i appreciate mr chairman
your
focus on this uh broad but very critical
issue
that has so much relevance of seeing
through the implementation of the
affordable care act
i represent a state that has urban
concentrations as well as
perhaps not as large spaces of rural
areas but certainly has the array of
challenges that are the subject of this
hearing and i
appreciate the attention that's going to
be focused on it um
one of the things that i hope that will
hear some elaboration on aside from
issues that compensation pays or
plays in this is the
questions of lifestyle for
primary care practitioners
things like the differences between the
amount of time that somebody might be
on call as a specialist versus a primary
care physician
as we look at larger payment reforms
how the flexibility in
their practice of being able to spend
the adequate time with a
patient for example with multiple
chronic conditions
that is necessary versus seeing folks in
in 15 minute increments etc
what impact will those policy changes
have
on the on the number
and a number of primary care
practitioners
in this country but anyways mr truman
thank you for
focusing attention on this issue and i
hope to return to
hear before from the witnesses and ask
my questions
thank you very much uh senator franken
uh thank you mr chairman for this this
incredibly important hearing we have
uh 30 million more americans we hope
if medicaid was adopted by the states
the expansion medicaid
leaving some people still uninsured
read the testimonies last night and it
is
very clear that when you insure people
their health care outcomes are better
and it actually costs us money when
people aren't insured and
so what we're doing and it's so clear
and i
i you know sometimes you hear well we
have health care in this country you can
just go to the emergency room
well that's the most expensive health
care and it doesn't mean that you get
treated after
the emergency room it doesn't mean that
you get what you need
to treat a chronic condition it it
all of your testimonies put the lie to
that
and i appreciate that uh in minnesota we
do health care
uh relative to the rest of the nation
extremely well um
hhs is rated as number one in high value
care and outcomes
divided by cost and we
like wisconsin
have kind of a combination of urban
centers and
not the miles and miles of miles and
miles but we have miles and miles
that the ranking member whom i would
like to welcome to this subcommittee and
i'm
looking forward to is partnering
on this and i admire his
his work on uh rural health which is
so important in in my state because
there are people that are underserved
one of the things that the chairman
talked about
was the student loans
that um you know graduating from
medical school with a typical uh
loan a debt of 160 000 sometimes more
and then talking about the tendency for
doctors then
who just graduated to say how am i going
to make
this money and we have
you know uh medpack
and this is an issue that you talk about
in your testimony
um in our country we pay specialists
on a ratio more than
uh primary care physicians than they do
in other
countries that do their health care very
successfully and cheaper
and less expensively than we do one of
the things about student loans to me
there's nothing good about high
the high cost of of college and of
graduate school in my mind except that
the only probably good thing is is that
it creates some
tool for us to
motivate people to go into the things
that we need
and the one question that i would like
the panel to think about
and i know you're going to give your
testimony we're going to do the
questions so
is what is a return on investment
if we say to
doctors graduating medical school
will we're doing some forgiveness we're
doing especially forgiveness for
being a primary care physician in a
rural area
or an underserved urban area but what
would
be the return on investment if we really
really encourage by loan forgiveness
doctors to go into primary care
in other words what what what is the
calculus there what's the equation
if we raise if we say my goodness it is
such
a benefit to society and such a cost
benefit
to have a higher ratio of primary care
physicians
that if we said for anybody who goes in
the primary care physician uh
medicine we will it's a hundred thousand
dollars
right there boom is there a cost
what's the cost benefit there uh
it's good to see you dr reinhart dr
reinhardt
and i have talked a number of times
he is a healthcare economist so maybe
that's something you can
mull over but anyway i thank you mr
chairman for this
unbelievably important hearing thank you
thank you senator franken uh senator
murphy
thank you very much mr chairman i'm
excited to be a member of this committee
and excited to be here with a fantastic
panel and so
i'll get out of the way so that you can
provide us with your testimony
let me just say this uh having chaired
the health committee in the
state legislature in connecticut for
years we grappled with this
problem year after year and i remember
specifically one meeting that i had
with about maybe 15 or 20
medical students at the university of
connecticut and
at some point in the meeting we were i
think talking about the affordable care
act and how it could help medical
students we're talking a lot about this
issue of
uh the high level of indebtedness and i
asked them how many of you are
considering not committed to but
considering going into primary care
and of the 15 students around the table
one of them raised their hand only one
was even considering it
and so we started to examine this
question as to why they weren't even why
did they didn't even have it on their
mind and
certainly the dollars were the first
thing that they mentioned all of them
were going to have extreme levels of
indebtedness even coming out of a state
university
and they just really couldn't figure out
how they were going to make that work
with the salary that they were going to
make as a primary care physician but
as you started to tease a deeper answer
out from each one of them the second
thing that came up was prestige that
they didn't feel that there was real
prestige any longer in being a primary
care physician that if you really wanted
to practice cutting edge medicine that
you had to go
into the specialties and they all had an
ego to them that wanted
uh to to put them on the front lines of
new medicine
and i hope that that's part of our
hearing as well today
is how do we put the practice of
medicine back into primary care
um how do we allow them to be more than
just gatekeepers
and i think that there's a perfect
opportunity as we start to roll out
these new
delivery system models as we envision a
world where accountable care
organizations and interconnected
uh multi-specialty practices are the
rule rather than the exception well we
invest in
things like medical home models you
allow
for primary care physicians to once
again
control a lot more medicine than they
used to control
the prestige comes back maybe not so
much in the medicine
they're practicing but in the control
they have over the healthcare system at
large
and so i think that as we build a new
delivery system it's an opportunity not
just
to address what i think is still the
most critical question which is
how do they just make their family's
budget work if they decide to go into
primary care but how do they
get to feel really good uh about the
medicine that they're practicing and the
value that they're adding
to their profession because um that's
been lost as well
over the years as the prestige has moved
to the specialists rather than the
primary care doctors and
i imagine we'll examine that topic today
as well thank you very much mr chairman
thank you senator murphy senator casey
mr chairman i'll submit a statement for
the record i just want to thank you for
calling this hearing it's a critically
important issue and we're
grateful that you did the work i guess
the one quick comment i'd make is when
we go to the
attending physician as members of
congress we have a doctor
available to us here in the capitol and
that doctor
in a sense is our quarterback who can
make
determinations about our health and can
refer us to
all kinds of specialists and others that
help us and we hope that
um one of the conclusions that results
or one of the
the goals here i guess is a better way
to say it of all this
all this work on the in this hearing and
otherwise
is that everyone has that primary care
doctor that quarterback in their life
who can treat them but also get them
access to specialists in the best care
thanks
senator casey senator hagin thank you
much
mr chairman and uh ranking member nc
thank you for holding this hearing today
i think this is a critical issue facing
our country today i know that in
my state of north carolina we have more
than a million uh people
who don't have access to
to primary health care because of a
shortage of providers
and i know that when patients can see a
primary health care doctor
they frequently end up getting care
obviously but what happens when they
don't have that access they go to the
hospital and that's where emergency care
and treatment is so expensive and it's
currently
helping to drive up the cost of health
care and also if you've got a chronic
disease and you can management
manage that disease it's much less
costly
and and otherwise they will develop into
acute care episodes
i know that there are innovations going
on in this area
and one of them is in north carolina the
blue ridge community health
services which is a community health
center in the western part of our state
it received a grant just this past
november under the teaching
health center program in the blue ridge
they've served 20
000 patients last year through 70 000
encounters with two primary care sites
four school-based health centers and one
dental center and they do outreach at a
local domestic violence shelter
and this funding that they have given
has allowed them to
increase the number of residents at this
facility
in hendersonville and i think those new
residents are really critical
to uh providing uh to helping with the
providing more primary health care
physicians blue ridge is one of 34
federally qualified health centers in
north carolina that do provide that high
quality
cost-effective care to so many people
across our state
and i know that there's another
provision that's important and that is
the rural physicians pipeline act
that was included in the affordable care
act and it gives the medical su
schools the resources to recruit
students from rural communities
so much of this primary care access is
lacking in
our rural communities and if we can
train physicians
from those rural communities they tend
to stay in rural communities
which i think is certainly a a highlight
of this provision so programs like that
i think have a significant role to play
in relieving this current primary care
shortage but i'm delighted to have this
committee hearing i look forward to
hearing the testimony
of all of our witnesses today thank you
thank you senator hagin senator
whitehouse
thanks very much senator sanders for
holding this hearing you've
drawn a big crowd i think because it's a
important issue
we are all gearing up here in washington
for
uh son of fiscal cliff which is going to
be coming in a couple of
weeks and
with that looming we're beginning to
hear the usual refrain about
how important it is to cut medicare
benefits
and to limit access
to medicare for seniors and that that's
the responsible thing to do to save
money
which of course is a preposterous and
ill-informed
idea uh particularly in the context of a
health care system that is 100 times
more expensive than it was in 1960
and if you look at the graph it's an
accelerating curve
of upward cost and when you look at a
2.7 trillion dollar
annual expenditure on health care that
is probably
50 higher but there's a 50 percent
inefficiency penalty that we pay in the
united states compared to
all of our industrialized competitors
the worst industrialized competitor is
12
of gdp we're at 18 of gdp it's 800
billion dollars a year spent
unnecessarily
you look at the scope of this you look
at the accelerating rocketing pace of
the increase
and you think you're going to solve that
by cutting medicare
it's simply not right as the ceo of
kaiser permanente
george halverson said that is an inept
way of thinking about health care
he said it's not just wrong it's so
wrong it's almost criminal
so hearings like this that point out
that there really is a problem with cost
and with the delivery system in the
united states and that we really have to
address
that problem if we're not going to
misdiagnose what we have
and once of course you know you have a
misdiagnosis you usually don't get the
right cure either
so it's really important that we not
throw
seniors and medicare under the bus
because we have failed to address
the real problem in health care which is
wild inefficiencies and
rocketing costs that aren't just in
medicare
indeed medicare is probably the most
efficient deliverer
of health care in our health care system
but if we get this right we don't just
40 of the savings will come back into
the federal budget
but the rest will go to kaiser to blue
cross to united to
businesses and families all across the
country so we've got a real fight on our
hands try to make sure we steer this in
the right direction and i hope this
hearing
helps make sure we make the right choice
senator whitehouse thank you very much i
want to remind
members of the senate and uh viewers on
c-span that the report that we have done
primary care access
uh is available at my website
sanders.senate.gov okay you
panelists have been extremely patient
but the good news is that what you've
seen today
is there is an enormous amount of
interest in this issue
so we're delighted that you're here uh
and we thank you again for
uh the work that you do let's begin with
uh dr fitzhugh
mullen uh dr mullen is the murdoch head
professor
of medicine and health policy at the
george washington university school of
public health
and professor of pediatrics at the
george washington university
school of medicine dr mulden thanks so
much for being with us
thank you chairman sanders and senator
enzi and colleagues
a great privilege to be here as a
primary care physician a pediatrician
who was in the first class of the
national health service corps in 1972
subsequently ran the national service
corps
it is not only a privilege but an
astounding developing history to hear
committee of the us senate speak with
such clarity
about the often orphan issues of primary
care
and service delivery in poor rural and
underserved communities
so i'm um if i can get over my days i
will
try to be cogent but thank you so much
for convening and for
the thought that's going into this i'm
going to run through
chairman sanders you gave my talk uh i
was supposed to be the expert you are
clearly the expert
so i will stint on some of the things
that i was going to bring up but try to
focus on the issues of
of education and system building around
primary care
the demand clearly is in front of us the
aging of the population
the advent of the affordable care act
and the terrific entitlement that it
provides
but that does present us with a
challenge just a few
demographics we have about 280
physicians per 100 000
in the united states which puts us in
the middle roughly of the developed
world
uk and canada have less germany and
france for instance have more
but we're roughly in the middle we have
about eight hundred thousand physicians
but additionally we have a hundred and
ninety thousand nurse practitioners
physician assistants
uh and certified nurse midwives so we
have almost a a twenty five percent
add-on
of providers that didn't exist 30 or 40
years ago
and a point on that important to
remember when
our workforce was lean and talking in
the 60s and 70s
we were very short and everybody
including the us congress agreed
and began a variety of programs that
have lived on very powerfully today
among those excuse me were the
development
of the nurse practitioner and the
physician assistant it didn't exist
before
and the national health service corps
excuse me
so lean is not necessarily bad
in terms of how we function if we want a
more
efficient system there are systems that
are used to
the uh payments that they currently get
and they're not going to change until uh
there is a real sense of need and we're
at that point
so while i'm not for holding where we
are now i think we need to think about
the advantages
perhaps and the creativity that can come
from this period
in terms of the primary care challenge i
look at it in two ways one is within
the factory the medical school the
teaching hospital and the other is in
the market
and clearly we've had eloquent testimony
as to the
pay parity gap that exists
in simple general terms a specialist
will make twice what a generalist makes
a generalist being your pediatrician
family doc general internist
and other
disciplines that are generalist in
nature and poorly paid
that is a huge problem and while
education
and training is very important what i do
and believe in
uh you can do the best education and
training and if you put them out in the
market with those kind of incentives
you'll get what we're getting now we've
got to deal with that
but speaking on the educational side uh
the the challenges are both at the
medical school level
and the residency level as you know this
prolonged adolescence we call residency
is very important
and also very influential in the nature
of the type of physician
and the location of the physician that
comes out of the education pipeline
there is in medical schools a culture
that is heavily at this point in time
specially focused a natural dominance of
the more research oriented and
subspecially sciences
which are well represented for good
reasons at medical school but the
primary care culture is often
put in the back of the bus and you will
not find a primary care physician who
hasn't been told at some point in their
training career
by a professor you're too intelligent
you're too smart
to go into primary care that culture is
toxic
and it's out there and we need to worry
about it the young doctor today is has
suggested drawn to lifestyle
specialties this is a problem too with
limited hours
clear and rather refined knowledge
requirements
and a predictable a life one can
understand those draws
but um we need to work on that and then
fun you have the sense of social purpose
and social mission
our medical schools have been well
treated by the nih that provides about
17 or 18 billion dollars a year
to research in medical schools by
medicare which provides 10 billion
dollars a year
to teaching hospitals or residency
programs 10 billion dollars a year about
100 000
per resident very very strong influence
with no requirements in terms of
workforce
product at the other end and given those
two pay streams
we put about 300 million dollars into
primary care family medicine nurse
practitioners pas
and about 300 million into the national
health service corps so you've got 27
billion on one
side that is generally specially
oriented and about 600 million
that is promoting primary care careers a
huge imbalance again not surprising
uh the outcome that results from that
the teaching health centers which have
been referenced a very important
innovation
it moves the paradigm out of the
hospital into the community and
importantly
needs to guarantee a pay stream we can't
run a residency without predictability
that is a very very important outcome
and it's something that needs attention
the nurse practitioner pa is a very
important asset as i say
almost 190 000 we need more they're more
nimble
they are easily more easily trained in
larger numbers
and that's a very very important feature
as we look at scaling up quickly
our workforce finally data and planning
we have a national healthcare workforce
commission finally voted in through the
aca it has not been funded is not met
we need a better brain in our somewhat
encephalic system our system without a
good brain
delete it that would be very helpful
finding conclusion
we have a moral triumph in the aca and
the entitlements that it brings
but also a technical challenge in terms
of legislative issues the
made permanence of the thcs is important
uh the full funding
and greater funding of the national
health service corps will be essential
bringing the national health workforce
commission to life is important
and perhaps most important is medicare
gme we need to get a handle
and use that 10 million dollars in a
more constructive pro-primary care
fashion
thank you thank you very much dr mullen
in order for us to have a good
vigorous question and answer if people
could keep their uh remarks to five or
six minutes that would be appreciated
uh our next witness is tess kinning she
is the executive director of bi-state
primary care association
whose members include the federally
qualified health centers in vermont and
in new hampshire ms kinning thanks very
much for being with us
chairman sanders um ranking member enzi
and distinguished members of the
subcommittee my name is tess kenning and
i am the executive director of bi-state
primary care association located in
montpelier vermont and concord new
hampshire and on behalf of the entire
health center community including more
than 22 million patients
nationwide and the national association
of community health centers
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to testify on the role of community
health centers
in addressing our nation's pressing
primary care access needs
as the committee is aware two important
events have significantly altered the
health care financing
and delivery systems of our nation the
patient protection and affordable care
act
and the supreme court's decision about
the same as a result of these events it
is estimated that as many as
30 million americans will gain coverage
through medicaid and or the health
insurance exchange
yet another 30 million will still remain
uninsured
we strongly support these coverage
expansions which open the door to a
broader health care system for many of
our patients
however we know well that coverage alone
does
not equate to access it is access to
regular care that makes coverage
meaningful
we also believe to achieve a truly
reformed health system
our nation needs sustainable solutions
to increase our primary care capacity
lower and manage our health care costs
and assure quality outcomes
it is for this reason in my view that
any efforts to increase access
to insurance must grow and expand
our primary care infrastructure
community health centers offer a unique
and proven solution to these challenges
by statute and mission community health
centers are located in medically
underserved areas
and serve medically underserved
populations and care for everyone
regardless of your ability to pay
community health centers also are
directed by patient majority boards
ensuring care is locally controlled
and responsive to each individual's
community's needs
it might surprise you to learn that the
community health center burlington in
burlington vermont
provides translation for patients from
the sudan bosnia somalia burundi tibetan
nepal
bhutan and burma to name only a few the
ability to receive care in one's native
language removes a major access barrier
and improves the health of these
families and our communities
from my years of clinical practice as a
nurse in nepal
i am able to speak nepali with our
increasing immigrant and refugee
population from nepal
and bhutan and i see firsthand the
benefits of this type of enhanced
provider-patient relationship can yield
without access to primary care many
people including these families
might delay seeking treatment until they
are seriously ill
and require hospitalization or care in
the emergency room
at a much higher cost to themselves and
to the health care system
the literature backs up these real world
experiences for example the journal of
rural health article
found that counties with a community
health center had
25 percent fewer emergency room visits
other data demonstrate the community
health center save the entire health
system
including government and taxpayers
approximately 24 billion dollars
annually
by keeping patients out of these
costlier health care settings
unfortunately congress with the
leadership of this
fortunately congress with the leadership
of the subcommittee's chair
had the foresight to include mandatory
funding to expand the reach of the
nation's community health centers in the
affordable care act
to ensure that the promise of coverage
was met with the reality of care
we believe that seeing this plan through
is essential unfortunately
the community health center expansion is
not currently on track
a recent ursa solicitation for new
access point grants anticipates
spending only 20 million dollars of the
300 million dollars
in new fiscal year funding fiscal 13.
the administration has instead proposed
spreading out the community health
center growth over a much longer
period of time and we urge that the full
affordable
care act provided increase for fiscal
year 13 be immediately
extended to care for two and a half
million new patients
as congress intended the demand for
community health centers continues to
outpace the growth
and more than 60 million americans still
lack access to primary care
in vermont new hampshire in the near
term all of our 19 health centers have
identified needs
in their areas i would be remiss if i
fail to cite another vital program that
supports the goal of creating medical
homes
for under-served americans and that's
the national health service corps
the corps places trained health
professions in health shortage areas and
remains a key
partner in ensuring that community
health centers can meet the demand for
primary care
that is looming just around the corner
with the aca implementation
community health centers around the
country are ready they're willing
they're able to be leaders in reforming
our health system
community by community from the ground
up we appreciate your leadership
and look forward to your and the
committee's continued support
as we work to provide meaningful health
care access to all
thank you mr chairman thank you miss
kinnick um senator nancy is going to
introduce our third witness
thank you mr chairman it is my pleasure
to introduce miss tony deck lever
uh she's a resident of cheyenne which is
our biggest city at 66 000 people
we have 259 towns but we only have 14
towns where the population exceeds the
elevation
she she's familiar with
all of those and she currently wears
several different professional hats
she's a government affairs liaison for
the
wyoming nurses association and has
visited washington dc previously
to advocate for her fellow nurses ms
deklever is a state director for
skillsusa helping to improve the
country's workforce by recruiting and
preparing individuals for careers in
trade technical
and skilled service occupations
including health occupations
finally she's an independent consultant
who helps train individuals in cpr first
aid
medication administration and how to
become first responder she has a
bachelor's of science degree in nursing
from the university of northern colorado
in greeley
and is a certified emt she's received a
number of awards for outstanding service
on behalf of wyoming's nurses and
workforce development groups
and we're pleased to have her here today
and i know from my weekly
trips to wyoming that it took 13 hours
in
airplanes and airports for you to be
able to get here thank you
ms declave thanks very much for being
with us please
good morning chairman sanders and
ranking member ansi members of the
committee
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify today
senator nz stated i do represent the
wyoming nurses association i've been a
registered nurse for almost 30 years
and i've worked in acute care long-term
care education and administration
wyoming is the ninth largest state in
the us with almost a hundred thousand
square
miles of land but our population is the
smallest in the nation
with just a little over half a million
people wyoming's frontier
and rural environment impacts our health
care systems wyoming has 25
hospitals with 16 designated as critical
access
hospitals 25 beds or less
there are also two veterans hospitals
and 16 rural health clinics
wyoming has eight community health
centers three are special population
health centers
and three are satellites of larger
health care centers
when dealing with the expanded number of
patients and the barriers to care for
these patients
several components need to be considered
one is the ability for providers to be
able to practice to their full scope of
their education and licensure
another is addressing the shortage of
providers due to retirement
and a shortage of qualified faculty to
educate new providers
others include the perception of quality
of care and support funding for rural
areas
with baby boomers turning 65 at the rate
of 10 000 a day
there will be an increase in demand for
health care in traditional acute care
settings along with expansion of
non-hospital settings
such as home health care and long-term
care wyoming's practice act
nurses practice act allows advanced
practice nurse practitioners
to practice independently in our state
disability helps nurses provide
in provide patients in rural areas
access to primary care
unfortunately some federal laws and
regulations only limit
the nurses ability to practice at their
full scope
a quirk in medicare law has kept aprns
from signing home health plans of care
and from certifying medicare patients
for a home health benefit
in areas where access to physicians is
limited this prohibition has led to
delays
in home health services moreover the
delays in care inconvenience patients
and their families
and can lead to increased costs to the
medicare system
this occurs when patients are
unnecessarily left
in institutional settings or readmitted
after discharge because they did not
receive proper home care
a sufficient supply of nurses is
critical in providing our nation's
population
with quality health now and into the
future registered nurses
and advanced practice nurses are the
backbone of hospitals
community health clinics school health
programs home health and long-term care
programs
and serve patients in many roles and
settings according to the 2008 national
sample of surveyed registered nurses
over 1 million of our nation's 3.1
nurses are over the age of 50
with one quarter of these nurses over
the age of 60.
much like rural populations in that of
wyoming the provider population is aging
and near retirement age
this runs counter to the increasing need
of growing older population
and a regional or sporadic growth of
younger populations
studies have identified the retirement
of providers as one of the obstacles to
providing comprehensive care
wyoming responded to the increasing need
for nurses by creating a funding stream
that would assist nurses to continue
their education and work as faculty at
the community colleges and university
this allowed the nursing programs to
increase their enrollment numbers
and thus educate more registered nurses
rns are encouraged to continue their
education
into the advanced practice nursing level
wyoming has a small amount of state
incentive and loan repayment money for
students
but the dollar amounts do not meet the
demean do not meet the demand
through each biennium to fill this void
in funding some
students are able to receive funds from
title viii
and title vii the perception that health
care also is delivered
in bigger health centers equals quality
is not easily overcome
many residents are using health services
in surrounding states
who could have been served in wyoming to
address this issue one report suggested
ways to recharacterize the system
by having a stable supply of primary
care providers
have appropriately located tertiary
centers integrate services at the point
of care
medical home concept collaborative
planning and policy implementation
effective use of pooled financial
services or resources
shared responsibility for achieving
goals for individual health
and organized leadership that keeps the
state responsive to changing needs
federal designations provide eligibility
for federal programs like hersa 330
funding
and enhanced reimbursements to rural
health clinics health provider shortage
areas medically underserved areas
and medically underserved populations
are based on factors
that make it difficult to prove the
needs of the underserved in rural and
frontier areas
as noted by senator enzi one provider
for 3 500 people in an
urban setting is entirely different than
3 500 people
living in a county that is almost 10 500
miles of land mass
wyoming's economy is based primarily on
energy production
coal natural gas oil uranium and even
wind
making it a boom and bust economy many
people working in the energy industry
make a sufficient salary when they work
but in some cases these salaries are
significant enough that it can show
skew the average income for families
based on statewide
data though some families do very well
financially
there are still a number of people
struggling to make ends meet
this income disparity can be another
challenge to meeting designation
guidelines committee members thank you
for your time
and attention to this very very
important matter and i look forward to
any questions you may have
missed thank you so much for being with
us and thanks for your testimony
uh our fourth witness is dr andrew
wilper
he is the acting chief of medicine at
the va medical center in boise idaho
dr wilper is a practicing general
internist he is the associate program
director
for the boise internal medicine
residency program and the assistant
director of the boise
va center of excellence in primary care
education
dr wilpa thanks very much for being with
us
thank you chairman sanders uh ranking
member enzi and members of the committee
it's a great honor to be able to testify
here today
i was asked by senator sanders about my
insight
two insights specifically one about the
lack of health insurance in the united
states and its effect on health and
health care outcomes
and also to share my thinking on
practical solutions to the primary care
physician workforce
shortage that we face so to start off
there is an enormous literature that has
accrued over decades
demonstrating that a lack of health
insurance is associated with
decreased access to health care and
worse health outcomes
the institute of medicine summarized
these findings in a six volume series
earlier this century and the conclusions
were quite clear
subsequent work has built on this
evidence including some of my own that
senator sanders mentioned
in his opening statement specifically a
paper we published in 2009 in the
american journal of public health
linking lack of insurance to nearly 45
000 deaths
among adults in the united states
annually
the research is consistent health
insurance leads to significant benefits
and is good for your health
so gaining access does or excuse me
gaining
health insurance does not guarantee
access to medical care which is the
second part of my testimony
nor does it control costs and perhaps
the singular intervention that
we could make at the national level to
to reduce costs
and improve outcomes in our country with
regard to health is to
bolster our primary care workforce
there's a an additional massive body of
literature supporting
the idea that primary care improves all
sorts of health outcomes
and lower costs nevertheless we've not
seen systematic changes to alleviate the
shortage of pcps in the us in decades
so i'll talk a little bit about sort of
three policy levers that i see
that this committee could consider to
increase the number of physicians
entering into the primary care workforce
some of which have been referred to by
professor mullen
first at the medical school level this
is the period of time after which people
graduate from college and are in their
undergraduate medical training
we could introduce additional
educational debt reduction
change federal funding streams to
emphasize primary care and
increase funding for the national health
service corps
in addition we could direct support to
community health centers to incentivize
third and fourth year medical students
to enter into primary care careers
second point would be the area of
graduate medical education
first title seven funding is
specifically earmarked to go toward
primary care programs and these are
continuously under threat of
congressional cut and have been cut
dramatically in the past 10 years
so re emphasizing that funding would be
an important step
a second piece would be direct payment
by medicare to teaching hospitals for
to offset the expense of training
physicians
as we've heard today that nearly 10
billion dollars is spent
by the federal government to support
these hospitals